[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
saw the headline yesterday
and it was uh from bob kravitz and it
says
was i wrong about deflategate question
mark six years later it's still
complicated i go
wait a minute what is going on here we
got to hit the wayback machine we're
still trying to figure out the flight
gate
long time columnist for the indianapolis
star friend of the show bob kravitz
senior staff writer for the athletic
bob what the hell's going on here well
you know i got a chance to see this
documentary four games in fall
and you know i found it very compelling
i found it very one-sided but i found it
very compelling and i thought you know
uh over the years i've had a chance to
read more
about deflategate because i have no life
and it just it raised some
questions in my mind that i did not have
previously have i come over to the dark
side
no um but it's certainly um
you know if you if you like to think of
yourself as a relatively open-minded
person
uh there are certainly some pretty uh
interesting elements to the uh
documentary that make you think twice
about it okay give me
the biggest piece of information that
you gleaned from this documentary that
made you hit the pause and
maybe have an epiphany on deflategate
well i
i think um the the history of exponent
no i think that and that's of course the
the company that
did all the research um for the wells
report
and um their history of being
a doubt science uh entity being a
science for hire
if you look at some of the people
they've they've represented over the
years
um they produced results
that were the desired results for
certain companies
and i found that very off-putting i was
aware of that at some level as it was
going on but
you know four five six years later
it it just it just struck me again as
being very compelling
okay take us back to that night and
and and you get ready to to hit send so
the colts just got roughed up by the
patriots
how do you get the information well
first i went downstairs to the locker
room and i did a
an hour-long post-game show and i forgot
my phone
because that's kind of thing i do so i
get back up to the press
box look at my phone see a text from
somebody saying call me immediately
call this person get the information
i'm like holy crap what what what have i
fallen into well what's the information
the information is that the patriots are
being investigated
for allegedly using deflated footballs
okay so it was 100 right it was 100 so
i spent the next i don't know 45 minutes
or so
looking for either confirmation or
denial
and i was able to get confirmation from
someone i felt very strongly about
as a source and said let's let it roll
let's let it ride
and uh tweeted it out and then all hell
broke loose
i have a real problem with it sounds
like feels like there was somebody
inside the nfl who was leaking bad
information
slanted information uh throughout this
process
well i certainly think that uh you know
mort
uh who i respect you know more than just
about anybody in
our business uh i think the nfl
used him i don't believe it
used by the league i i feel like
i was just given some information that
was 100 percent accurate
but why would they use more though
because of his his status because i mean
if you
if you use mort or adam or whoever
it might be i mean you get the most bang
for your buck in that
in that fashion though well but i don't
understand it felt like they
hey we committed to this now we got to
go to the mat and we got to bring
brady and the patriots in here instead
of saying hey you know what they may
have done this
or it felt like there was a less a less
heavy-handed way of approaching this
from the nfl bob
i agree and look you you look at the nfl
and
and the way they've looked into various
issues over the years the ray rice
fiasco
i mean these guys they're incompetent in
many ways and i thought that they
handled this
incompetently uh i think the media
uh to some degree got got caught in the
dragnet to some degree
and you could also make the argument
that we allowed ourselves to get caught
in that dragnet
i never cared about the footballs but
i don't know why the nfl cared about the
footballs this the aaron rodgers
came on the show and said he
overinflates the football like i
i don't i think this has happened for
decades here
why all of a sudden the patriots
well i i think because they do have the
priors and i think don van atta and seth
wickersham
wrote a really good piece for espn.com i
think is about two years ago
that many ways this was a makeup call
for the way they handled spygate and
you know that was gay that they did not
go to the mat they they took it easy on
the patriots
for the most part and so i think it was
a makeup call
to some degree i think they're getting a
lot of a lot of grief from a lot of
other owners
who feel like the patriots play fast and
loose with the rules
and i think this is how it came down man
that's dangerous though bob
of course it is it's so dangerous what's
really dangerous is that
the nflpa gave goodell
unilateral power to rule on disciplinary
issues
and so whether you think the science was
flawed
whether you think the uh the
investigation was flawed they used the
media in
in in myriad ways the bottom line is
goodell for right or wrong has the
freedom
has the right to make the call make the
judgment call there
what do you think now about deflategate
i still and this is more
a feeling it's not provable i think
something happened
i think something happened i you know
here's the deal i i look at
the science from exponent or another
company or another
scientist and i think well that makes
sense
and then i read then i watch the guy
from mit dr
leonard and i think that makes sense
i don't know what classes you took at ud
but
none when i was in it when i was in
indiana i didn't take
class i mean i took physics for poets
you know
i mean my i i
you know i the the gay luzak
law what the hell do i know about that
so you know when i read one ivy league
guy
say they're guilty i think that's
probably the case when i read another
ivy league guy
who says that they are i think you know
i i i'm
it's sort of beyond my comprehension is
what i'm saying yeah
i i just they'd been doing this for
years
this this wasn't something new to beat
the colts
and other quarterbacks have told me
privately that they've done this
that they should be able to do this that
this is one of those
well that's the rule and then we're
gonna we got you
and then oh you're lying to me and then
there's the deflator and all i mean it
just felt like
it careened out of control it didn't
need to
and the fact that you would do a try to
do a makeup for spygate man is that
dangerous
yeah it is it absolutely is yeah i mean
look
when i when i broke the story i thought
this will be a two-week story
boy was i wrong uh i don't wish you
never
sent that do you wish you'd never no i'm
absolutely
glad that i did okay because it was
right dan whether
they were guilty of it or not what i
wrote
was that they are being investigated
that was 100
correct now where i screwed up and i
made this point in mike in my column the
other day in the athletic
was that i saw what mort had written
about 11 of 12 balls being two
pounds uh per square inch underweight
and with it and i'm i'm not taking shots
at mort because i again
he's a friend and i think he's great at
what he does but
he got used in that situation
and the mistake i made was using that
as a jumping off point to viscerally
react through tweets saying you know
belichick should have his head on a
platter that was a mistake by me i got
too far over my skis
but but this now the real story is and
is somebody going to do the real story
on who is the person
inside the nfl who was leaking this
false information
because that's what i want to know
that's at the crux of
of a lot of this it feels like bob i i
don't
you know you the uh the woman you spoke
to uh
who is uh part of the documentary yeah
julie maron
she says the nfl deliberately lied about
things withheld information
spent months digging into the construct
uh to construct a narrative
to me the fact that they could do this
is arguably the most
successful player in the league was
pretty chilly yeah that's the story
like they're doing this they're eating
their own they're going after brady
i i don't disagree with you i i'm not
sure
you know that that's that's something
they're ever going to be you know i mean
certainly i'm not going to talk about
the people that i spoke with certainly
mort's not i think mort has done a bit
of a maya culpa
on it i i i'm not completely sure but i
think he
uh has acknowledged that the information
was not uh was not correct so
yeah did you ever speak to brady
i never have i never have i'd love to
i loved it i really did i mean i got
nothing to
i've got nothing to be ashamed of i mean
they were they were
uh investigating i wrote that they were
investigating end of story
oh this is one of those it's attached to
the patriots so it's going to live on
forever
if it was if it was the bengals nobody
would care
but it was the patriots it's tom brady
and
it'll live on it'll be part of the
legacy of uh every one of those
those uh key ingredients there it'll be
on my epitaph
sadly i was wondering how many lines in
to your epitaph do they mention
deflategate with bob kravitz
first first line yeah got to be
and i'm not happy about that necessarily
i'd like to think that you know i've
done 37 years of
pretty solid work uh at some really good
publications
so i i i would not like that to be uh
the first line of the epitaph but i'll
take the second or third yeah but keith
oberman's going to be in the first line
of my epitaph how do you think i feel
about that
that's depressing no uh that's
we're forever intertwined as you are
with deflatecon absolutely
bob good to talk to you as always good
to talk to you dad thank you thank you
buddy that's bob kravitz
works for the athletic indianapolis star
columnist for a long time